Right up front, I use the word:
and those are all perfectly good biological words
associated with structures and behaviors
that fulfill an absolutely critical biological role.
Certainly there are people who might be
taken aback a little bit, surprised.
But I tell you, once i actually tell people that
I study genitalia and that I look at penises and vaginas,
I have never had anybody say:
"Oh my gosh, that sounds terrible."
Or be bored for any amount of time.
I mean they  all just want to sit there and hear these
incredible stories about how animals
actually go about the business of having sex.
My name is Patty Brennan
and  I'm an  evolutionary biologist.
I work at Mount Holyoke College
in the Department of Biological Sciences.
I'm interested in a wide group of vertebrates.
So we have been collecting many animals.
The work I do is essentially evolutionary morphology
So, I need to be able to describe
what the genitalia looks like.
So, dissections of animals and structures.
We can actually make molds.
Then look at the histology:
just the basic architecture of the tissue.
And then I need to know how they work, so I've been
testing the material properties of vaginas.
But because they don't function independently
then i also need to know how the genitals function
with each other.
That means 3D models and
essentially use that to predict then
what are the structures that are under selection
for evolution to actually take place
and end up with this:
So these are the mako shark.
And so the males have these genitals attached to
their pelvic fins and when the males are
going to copulate they typical use only one of these.
So they'll use one clasper.
So the clasper will go in the female.
And then, once the male is inside of the female
He will actually pull down on a muscle
and essentially open up the tip of the clasper.
The tip of that is called a spur.
You'll actually feels it's really sharp.
And what that's going to allow him to do
is stay attached until he's able to deliver the sperm.
Isn't it the most beautiful thing?
I think this is just really incredibly cool.
Diagrams that I find— there will be like this description
of the claspers but there's nothing at all on the vagina.
Essentially there's very little consideration given to:
" Well where's this clasper actually going
and what is it doing?"
And so that surprised me, again in a good way
because it means that I have
an interesting question to go look at.
So when we have the females we can actually make
molds of the vagina.
Essentially I use silicone and then I inject the silicone
so it flows into all the crevices
and all the spaces of the female.
We let it cure and then we pull it out and then
that gives us a 3D image of the
negative space inside of the vagina.
Here we have the mako female
and she was a very large female.
And this is the intestine so from here,
the intestine would go up that way.
So that clasper most likely is coming in
from the entrance here of the cloaca
and it's probably going right
through this little notch right here.
And then once it gets past that point then
the male pulls out on that clasper muscle
to open it up and then dig right in there
and just hook itself to the female
so  that then he can ejaculate and all his sperm
will go up inside of the female tract.
The sharks have these long spines, spurs
in their claspers but other animals like
snakes for example they also have spines.
These are timber rattlesnakes.
They were run over by cars and so I got these locally.
The three-dimensional shape of the structure
for the males hasn't been described, so we'll do that.
We're about to inflate the male hemipene so that they
get as close as they can to their functional shape.
And I'm saying hemipene because like sharks
the snakes have two penises instead of one.
And they'll use one or the other when they're copulating.
Perfect.
This is the mold that we just pulled out of the female.
We can describe how it's variable,
we can look at the differences in the shapes.
So these are all different species of snakes.
We have a rattlesnake, that's the big one we just did.
Then we have a plains garter snake.
And then a python and then a yellow rat snake.
We know that the vaginas need to be elastic
because they're used also for the babies to be born
or the eggs to be laid right?
But is there anything above and beyond that
that is the result of actual copulation
and interacting with those spines?
We don't know whether that's the case or not
in snakes because it hasn't been looked at.
And so one of the things we want to do is
then look at the histology:
What those tissues are in the females
but also the thickness and the relative
proportion of these tissues
in all these different species.
This is beautiful, look at that one.
Oh, wow.
What we can see here is lots of smooth muscle
in the red  and then over here in the blue is
lot's of connective tissue.
Then we can inflate the male's inside of the female
And we'll put them in a micro CT scanner
And we can get images of
where the male features end up inside of the female.
And it's obviously not exactly what happens
during copulation but it's the closest we're going to get
when we look at these large vertebrates.
There's a lot more to discover
in the female side of things
that's going to really help us
understand then the male part of things.
I mean these have not evolved in a vacuum.
They have co-evolved so closely—more closely
than any other structure that we can think about.
For me, I'm really excited about the process
of discovering and so I do actually tend to
seek out areas where there is something
that is not well understood
or that we don't have all the details.
That's what happens sometimes in science,
you just gotta follow the questions
wherever they take you, and so here I am.